[Music]
there is a stranger coming to this
village in the sea comes in the winter
when people are hungry big fish comes on
the king guys I was last night
[Music]
you
I just wants a quick thanks to my cast
and crew some great sheet and thanking
UK an amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
surprise surprise youtubers you wake up
early in the morning you get new Justice
League footage so there is a trailer
dropping later this week but I wanted to
post this as fast as possible I'll do a
bigger Justice League video later today
so be sure to subscribe to get that I'll
be givin away a new copy of injustice 2
and as you can see from the teasers
they're hyping up Aquaman they finished
the visual effects the water looks way
different it's almost like the footage
they showed off at Comic Con which is
way more polished so it's going to be a
much more expanded version of that I'm
expecting the actual footage they show
up to be somewhere around a minute
minute and a half but this is all for
WonderCon this weekend so just short
takeaway everybody that's been seeing
the behind the scenes stuff going to the
test screenings say that he is going to
be the thing that everybody loves from
this film everybody always has their
favorite character the flash is
definitely one of my favorite characters
now in Jeff John's definitely bunched up
Aquaman during his run during the new 52
but I feel like Jason Momoa is the guy
that is going to make Aquaman the
badasses a DC EU so let me know in the
comments who is your favorite DC movie
character right now I know we haven't
seen a lot of the other characters yet
like we barely saw Aquaman and that may
be a Superman we barely seen the flash
but even with all the crazy drama I
still feel like Ben Affleck's Batman is
going to kill it and I'm really excited
for Wonder Woman even though we haven't
seen a lot of that movie yet so what's
going to happen is in a little while I'm
going to post the most hardcore episode
video of arrow ever literally the most
hardcore episode of that show ever and
then I'll post new Justice League
tonight is going to be crazy so I'm so
excited so I will see you guys in a
little while while you wait for that you
can click here for the new Wonder Woman
trailer and you can click here for a new
infinity war black border thank you so
much for watching let's I thought I'll
see you guys in a little while
you